[Music]
[Applause]
Mona Shelburne from the mothership a
senior writer NBA today panelist and
joining us on the program random
question to start out would you rather
have Klay Thompson's career or Scottie
Pippen's career
um I think a hundred percent Klay
Thompson because that would mean that I
spent my life in Oakland with Steph
Curry
right it was a really fun guy to hang
out with and Clay to me is a he likes to
go fishing in the San Francisco Bay uh
you know he's Steph is like a really
nice gentler
co-star Superstar and like Michael
Jordan's breathing fire at me every day
like Michael Jordan's gonna tear my head
up if I miss that defensive rotation
deceptions might like might look at me
bad but you know much better workplace
environment I think all right uh based
off last night how much confidence do
you have in Golden State or how much
confidence do you have in the Lakers
um I picked Golden State in seven in
this series and I think I stick with it
because
the part it wasn't the home court
advantage that gave me the confidence in
them in the series I thought it was the
fact that they had been there so many
times in this ever the playoffs are a
chess match every game every half every
possession is just adjustment adjustment
adjustment and I thought they've just
done this so many times for LeBron's
done it a lot but none of the other guys
on the Lakers roster have really done
this in a sustained way for more than
really just Anthony Davis in in the
playoffs in 2020. we're still trying to
figure out Anthony Davis yeah
it feels like we're going to continue to
still try to figure out Anthony Davis
why why is he such an enigma
you know um somebody very influential in
Lake or land said this to me two or
three years ago
um we don't really know what makes him
tick
right like like there's certain
Superstars
um who you understand who they are right
like at his core like you kind of
understood what Kobe was about you you
understood what what he wanted out of
out of his career and out of every game
um I think you understand what LeBron's
about I mean LeBron you know if Kobe
wanted to be Michael I think LeBron
wanted to be Jay-Z right I mean he's
he's both a billionaire off of the court
and a mogul off the court but a
um four-time Champion wants to be five
times six time if he can on the court uh
you know to me he's his closest
comparison as a player is Magic right
he's he's he's six nine and can
distribute the ball I don't know I don't
know what makes Anthony Davis tick like
I don't know is he trying to be an
all-time great Center does he is he
motivated by fear of like I don't want
to fall short is he motivated by
um you know I I want to prove myself to
LeBron or I want to shut Charles Barkley
up with the street clothes stuff like I
don't know what it is that that makes
him in that fundamental sort of fire way
tick
um but I don't think that's like yeah
that Pau Gasol yeah Powell didn't have
that fiery temperament right but it but
it worked why did it work with Powell
and you had Kobe there yeah staring him
down but is is that what it takes that
you know almost a fear of failure with
Kobe there breathing down
yeah I mean literally Kobe I mean that
was the Black Swan White Swan stuff but
I think two things about Pau Gasol it's
a great it's a great comparison
um I thought pal wanted to be excellent
pow is a high achiever he's like uh
would have gone to medical school if he
wasn't a basketball player he is
somebody who when he when he messes up
when he when he um doesn't bring his
best in a game he's disappointed in
himself because he knows he can do
better like he's a he's a he's your
classic High achiever in school high
achiever in life and when he disappoints
himself he disappoints you don't need to
even tell him right he already knows
Anthony Davis I think he a lot of times
he gets down on himself when he when he
is not playing up to his level in 2020 I
thought he was really motivated by
LeBron LeBron was sort of his
um his Kobe if you will all right like
he wanted to impress LeBron he wanted to
prove to LeBron like I have the
championship medal I I see LeBron talk
to Anthony Davis the way Toby talked to
Powell but it's not LeBron's personality
like he's never gonna Black Swan White
Swan him right he's never gonna he's
never gonna try to motivate him in that
way so I really think that it has to
come from within with Anthony
um the best person to talk to about
Anthony usually is his dad he you know
he's a he's known him his whole life he
knows what motivates him and uh he
always tells me about the championship
game in Kentucky where Anthony didn't
really have a great game but he played
lights out defense and he he had one of
his best rebounding games much like you
saw in that Memphis series or you and
and I think for it for Anthony the the
key is really not to get down on himself
is to focus on what you can do for the
team rather than what you're not doing
when things are bad like a lot of what
people in Laker land talk about is
keeping him up keeping him from getting
down on himself
um and that's a different wiring for a
superstar than you normally see
well I I notice when you engage him
early then yeah and he's successful
early then I know he's going to give me
something at the other end as well and
it's almost like you know later in
Kareem's career magic got him engaged
early yeah so he didn't sort of drift a
little bit and that's game one he was
engaged game two he never got it going
and there was a three-minute stretch
last night I didn't know he was on the
floor yeah I mean there's I saw some of
those defensive highlights like I always
I like to read Anthony Slater's
breakdown articles in the athletic
afterwards he had a couple clips and it
was like A.D on defense and it was like
he was just walking around like and I
was like I've never seen A.D walk around
on defense that's and that to me is hey
I thought he was really fatigued after
game one and it was a it was a quick
turnaround like he played so hard every
single one of those 44 minutes in game
four and starting again in game one and
I don't I don't know if you can play
with that level of force yeah two games
in a row with that short of a turnaround
and especially not when you're already
down 20. like I I almost felt like it
was closed for a little while they fell
behind by too much and then they just
kind of they're just kind of saving it
for game three and four at home we're
talking to Ramona Shelburne uh ESPN NBA
Insider senior writer NBA today panelist
I don't know if it's recency bias but
this is a topic that's come up if Steph
would win a title and now he's got five
where is Steph and then people even said
he would move past LeBron
I mean those are the two dominant
players of their era okay and I'm and
I'm not including Giannis yet in that
era because I think he's younger okay
steps 35 LeBron's 38 so Giannis he's got
a few he's a little younger
um and a little more time to go but I
don't know it Steph is a really
interesting comparison for everyone he's
the closest comp to me and this is going
to sound weird but it's it's really Tim
Duncan
um he's this sort of unappreciate like I
mean you appreciate him of course people
appreciate him they think that he's
great but he sort of gets tagged with
this system player uh the year when
everyone was hurt and then you know it
was just kind of him all alone they
finished eighth remember that year two
years ago
um and there was this thought like you
you know he needs clay and Draymond and
a team around him whereas if you had
Michael Jordan or but if you had just
LeBron they could carry a team I I think
that narrative is false like I've seen
LeBron when he doesn't have the right
team around him we saw that at the
beginning of this year when he did have
the right team around him right and they
were they barely finished seventh so to
me Steph to will 100 will be remembered
as the greatest shooter of all time
that's that's like out of the question
at this point like he's already got that
um now I think when you get to five now
you're in a totally different group of
players now you're up there with magic
you know there's like you're not quite
to Jordan yet but but there's a there's
a Kobe's got five magic like this is a
different Echelon of all-time greats and
um
stuff well I don't think he gets enough
credit because of the two he won with
Durant you know Durant was clearly the
finals MVP but these if he wins another
one another late career title where he's
the man he's the Superstar just like
that first title they won I think that
puts him in it in in that rarified air
whereas LeBron to me I think he goes
down right next to Michael 1a1b as the
as the greatest players of all time just
because it's not just about the scoring
or the titles or anything like that it's
just I mean it's just the eyeball test
right I mean like you watch LeBron and
there's never been a six nine guy who
plays with as much force as LeBron does
with as much skill
were the Bucks looking for a reason to
fire Mike budenhauser yeah it's been out
there for a while right I mean that I
feel like I've heard the fire Bud stuff
for two years three years and the year
they finally won the title in 2021 like
it almost felt like he had to win a
title not to get fired I mean it just
felt like in that direction then he won
and they go okay well you'd stay for a
little bit
um but it was it was one slip up away
and it is kind of remarkable though I
was thinking about this last night when
I was watching The Warriors so 20 2019
Nick nurse wins the title now he's been
fired 2020 Frank Vogel wins the title
now he's been fired 2021 Mike
budenholster wins the title now he's
been fired who won a 22. Steve Steve
and he is the only guy who like when you
talk about sustainability as a as a team
and as a coach it's really hard to do
that in this era especially with giant
personalities like you have to have a
superstar to win a title okay
um I don't know this this one this one
hurts because we all know what he's been
through personally with his brother and
everything the last you know the last
month or so
um but it really comes down to your
Superstar I mean they're never gonna
fire a coach without running it by the
star I remember when when they got rid
of Jason Kidd before this you know they
they told Giannis and he tried to save
him you know he really had a bond with
Jason Kidd
um you know flat out at the end of the
last game he said I thought we could
have made more adjustments but that's on
the coach I mean so I think this is
about the relationship between Giannis
and Mike budenholzer if it was a great
one if it was something that he would go
to the mat with
um Mike would still be there
Ramona great to talk to you have a great
weekend thanks for joining us thanks Dan
Ramona Shelburne NBA Insider for the
mothership senior writer and she'll be
there for game three with the Lakers and
the Golden State Warriors also a
panelist for NBA today